describe yourself as the Bachelorette in
one word what's one adjective oh my gosh
direct now that you've been named the
first black lead people have literally
been tallying like here's how many
people of color on different seasons
what kind of pool are you hoping to see
in your group of contestants I mean I
obviously expect to see a wider pool of
african-american men just because that's
me but what I'm excited about is that
I'm hoping my cast reflects what America
looks like you know I don't just date
african-american man I've dated all
races before and so I'm hoping that the
cast reflects what America looks like
and I'm excited that my season is
hopefully the one that that has the
opportunity to do that overall it is a
big responsibility what are the
pressures that you're feeling talk a
little bit about that originally I felt
a lot of pressure because who doesn't
have pressure being the first at
anything but at the same time I'm what
outweighs that is I'm so humbled and
honored to be the one chosen to take on
this this role in this experience and
and it's not just a role in experience I
get the opportunity to find love so how
amazing is that
[Music]
you